bonsoir à tous ceux rares compromis aux
états unis entre deux parties qu'on
estimait condamné à l'immobilisme sur la
question des armes à feu un groupe de
sénateurs des républicains et des
démocrates ont conclu un accord pour en
retirer le contrôle le projet de réforme
qui comprend également un volet sur la
santé mentale et la sécurité dans les
écoles thèmes chers aux républicains
devra maintenant obtenir la base du
sénat mais c'est annoncé a à z est somme
toute assez timide oui caudines c'est
timide c'est modeste mais ici on parle
carrément de miracle pour que les
démocrates et les républicains un sens
en sait quelque chose même si c'est sur
un petit bout de texte tellement ce pays
est polarisée donc ils se sont entendus
sur un texte deux choses importantes
alors d'une part on retire les armes aux
personnes qui sont jugés instables ou
dangereuses et puis également un autre
point important on vérifie les
antécédents judiciaires et psychologique
des moins de 21 ans donc là dessus dit
sénateur républicain 10 sénateurs et
pouquoi démocrates se sont entendus mais
on est bien loin la du texte qui a été
adopté par la chambre des représentants
qui voulaient l'interdiction de fusil
semi automatique au moins de 21 ans et
puis celle de charger à grande capacité
également une vérification des
antécédents judiciaires de toutes les
personnes donc ouais on est loin de tout
ça mais quand même c'est un pas en avant
joe biden a dit que c'était significatif
ce qui s'est passé écoutons le sénateur
chris coons ceux du delaware
est
des moments où les narines organes ou
est ce tout
mais à zéro on est très loin des
réformes réclamées par la population et
on l'a vu hier avec toutes ces
manifestations partout au pays oui et
les familles aux états unis ont peur et
avec raison et hier et beaucoup de
familles des mères de famille des
enfants des pères de famille qui
vraiment craignent le pire là ils ont
tous été témoins de nature et aval des
c'était un jeune de 19 ans avec encore
une fois un fusil semi-automatique la
même chose lors de la tuerie abo volo
donc les gens ne se sentent pas du tout
protégé juste pour vous donner une idée
les sondages indiquent que 80% de la
population est en faveur de la
vérification d'antécédents judiciaires
et psychologique 72 12 % sont pour le
drapeau rouge c'est à dire pour que si
c'est une personne est dangereuse ou
instables faut surtout pas qu'elle est
une arme et puis 62 % sont pour
l'interdiction des armes
semi-automatiques donc la population
veut vraiment un changement et s'est pas
encore traduit là par une loi au congrès
écoutons le sénateur républicain quiz
jacob ce qui lui est un des rares
l'acquis pour l'interdiction des fusils
des fusils semi automatiques et
d'assommer dit que vraiment il fait
l'expression l'exception et qui les
ostracisé là par le parti républicain
donc très rapidement claudine ça prend
soixante sénateurs qui votent pour ce
projet de loi pour qu'il passe et puis
ensuite il va se retrouver sur le bureau
du président merci beaucoup à z awa
cheikh voir